mr i don't lose that nothing is back
correction mr just got unbanned from
scamming us back this time he's selling
nfts now i'm gonna tell you guys this is
an obvious scam if you can just read the
signs but since floyd can't read i'm
gonna explain it to you all by telling
you the history of floyd money
mayweather and crypto our story starts
in 2018 when floyd mayweather was banned
for three years from promoting
securities after scamming his fans with
an ico called cintratech he was
promoting tons of these ico scams at the
time and he also narrowly avoided an ico
fraud lawsuit for the same thing under
the defense that he wasn't actually
influential enough to convince people to
buy the scam and now that it's 2022 his
three-year securities ban is over and
he's back to scamming again he's
currently being sued once again for his
promotion of ethereum max alongside kim
kardashian and also has gotten really
into nfts and if you in the nft world
and you bet know me you will never lose
but what i need you to do right now go
get may reverse that's my new nft i've
been working on that for months if i win
you win now it's pretty obvious from
these comments that floyd has learned
nothing after not reading the sec
settlement so maybe that's why he tells
us we can't lose by betting on him so
let's put that to the test with his last
three nft projects
i'm dropping my nft
tonight floyd nft.com august 10th go get
it right now matter of fact don't even
wait till august 10th get it now my nft
on a piece of my legacy floyd money
mayweather i'm not just in 30 or 40
percent 400 percent about yeah i'm all
the way in now floyd's world was indeed
a huge success for floyd mayweather who
raked in 4.9 million dollars but what
happened to his fans well they're
furious because the price of this nft
has collapsed over 90 percent and they
angrily responded in the comments
section you already have an nft project
it's called at realfloyd nft you
released it last year and then stopped
working on it immediately after have you
been punched in the head so much you're
forgetting these things now yes ladies
and gentlemen i know it looks bad logan
paul may have rocked floyd more than we
care to believe but there's more to this
story board bunny is another nft scam
that floyd promoted anyone want to guess
how that went january 4th board bunny
will launch everybody stay tuned now if
you were dumb enough to stay tuned to
this one it dropped like a rock 90
losses and then of course you have the
board bad bunny project which floyd also
promoted which is like board bunny but
bad badder worse the nft world is on
fire
board bunny we killed the first one
right now we're about to drop another
board bunny but it's bored bad bunny
first one was crazy now this one
you got to check it out all right fine
floyd i'll check it out and uh
it went to zero
but if you thought those were all the
skeletons in floyd's closet you're wrong
meta skeletons i personally want to say
thank you to the artist and a team over
at metaskeletons that's right he wants
to thank them for paying him to say this
and you guys um your investment is uh if
we check the numbers on this oh god
right
it's
instead of these worthless now so to
summarize floyd money mayweather in a
way his fans can understand floyd is oh
and i with an astonishing two lawsuits
and one tko from the sec and he wants
you to bet on him he wants to go one
more round in the ring he wants to get
paid again and it doesn't sound like a
good idea to me when it comes to
legalize bank robbing i'm the best
[Applause]